bom dia
eu vim aqui tentar responder uma
pergunta que parece simples mas é
extremamente complexa que é uma pergunta
o que um hacker
o que é o rec eu acho que poucas
questões elas despertam tanto fascínio
hoje na sociedade como a como essa
figura é pouco compreendida
às vezes estigmatizada o termo hacker
ele já foi utilizado para se referir a
coisas tão diversas quanto programadores
e especialistas segurança em sistemas
ativistas artistas e empreendedores
fazedores em geral e muitas vezes até é
especialmente mais recentemente uma
derivação de sentido na educação na
cidade
o hacker eu já vi uma notícia uma vez e
da impressão assim que todo mundo quer
ser hacker é uma coisa que me intriga
muito porque muito embora tenha tido
contato com a computação bastante
criança e contato com o que pelo menos
aqui no brasil é considerado comum da
cultura hacker no começo dos anos 90
intrigante porque nesse período nos anos
90 e começo dos anos 2000 já trabalham
profissionalmente na área de segurança e
você não podia abertamente ter essa
ânsia de querer se auto-denominar rádio
primeiro porque não era uma coisa nunca
pegou bem né pra muita gente hacker é
sinônimo de genialidade
então você não pode esperar que ninguém
respeita se você se autodenomina gênio
mas também porque havia uma ação
negativa
e então eu dediquei grande parte
inclusive da minha vida profissional a
trabalhar em projetos para tentar acabar
com esse estigma transação porque eu
sempre achei que poderia ter
consequências muito ruins e mesmo tendo
organizado por exemplo realizei algumas
das maiores conferências que a gente tem
na américa latina sobre o tema é muito
focado nessa idéia de tentar acabar com
esse tipo de estigmatização
muitos de vocês poderiam achar que isso
seria o suficiente para me sentir
plenamente qualificado a pegar e trazer
para vocês uma definição mas eu não me
sinto
principalmente porque eu acho que várias
outras pessoas já trouxeram essa
definição
então eu vou preferir na realidade
contar pra vocês uma história uma
história que pode se confundir com a
história pessoal de muitos vocês pessoas
que se apaixonaram pela tecnologia assim
que viram qualquer coisa que remetesse
um computador quase que de maneira
instantânea mas uma história que é muito
pouco conhecida mesmo daquelas pessoas
que trabalham de maneira muito próxima a
essa cultura né
o que vocês estão vendo aqui é uma
maquete do tech móvel high road clube é
um clube de ferro modelismo do emitiu
instituto de tecnologia de
massachussetts
esse clube é considerado de maneira
documental um dos berços assim da
cultura hacker sabe que dá um baita
trabalho fazer maquetes desse tipo
normalmente envolve pessoas assim com
interesses bastante diversos a respeito
de uma série de coisas desde coisas mais
artísticas até coisas mais técnicas e um
dos subgrupos nec chamava subcomitê de
energia e sinalização
basicamente trabalhava desenvolvendo
circuitos né para controlar os
trenzinhos eles quando era nos anos 60 e
os computadores começaram a chegar no
haiti
eles foram instantaneamente fisgados por
isso aqui é um equipamento chamado t x 0
ele é um equipamento considerado meio
percursoras em 2000 e computadores sabem
que nessa
os computadores assim não eram
dispositivos exatamente falaram de
usabilidade aqui hoje não eram
exatamente dispositivos práticos não
havia praticamente mídia de
armazenamento você tinha que ter claro o
código numa espécie de uma máquina de
escrever que converti aquilo num cartão
perfurado e esses cartões perfurados
eram usados para abastecer as máquinas e
esses equipamentos custavam uma fortuna
e ficavam fisicamente trancados em
espaços reservados para quem estava
fazendo algum tipo de curso relacionado
aquilo que nem curso de computação na
realidade existe nessa época e esse
pessoal do time
eles foram instantaneamente fisgados
como é a história de muitas pessoas aqui
né de qq que tenha se magnetismo em
direção à computação e eles começaram a
querer de todo jeito entrar nessa sala e
se for um outsider eles não era pessoal
de matemática de física de eletrônica
elétrica que normalmente tinha acesso a
esses equipamentos eles não tinham e aí
eles começaram a forçar a barra eles
ficavam na porta da sala ficava
esperando alguém que estava reservado
para ter acesso ao equipamento não
aparecer para poder ter contato com
idéias mirabolantes possivelmente até
imaginando algo muito pouco prático tipo
que está a usar esse equipamento para
controlar os trenzinhos da maquete né e
pouca gente sabe mas o termo rec é um
termo bastante antigo dentro da cultura
do haiti ré que são basicamente
pegadinhas provocativas inteligentes
elaboradas dentro do campus
universitário que existem há décadas lá
e fazem parte da cultura acadêmica da
instituição muito tempo cobrir por
exemplo o domo da biblioteca com papel
alumínio numa madrugada e todo dia e no
dia seguinte todo mundo chegar lá olha
para aquilo acha legal né
é difícil explicar o que é legal mas que
também falou uma vez que o humor tentar
ficar o humor é igual ao tentar secar um
sapo né
você não acha nada dentro e acabou
matando a piada no meio do caminho mas
tem aquela coisa que você olha né por
cobrir a biblioteca de papel alumínio e
rapidamente você começa a se perguntar 1
como é que aquilo foi feito
ou seja tem um elemento de primazia
técnica tem um elemento até de expressão
pessoal
quem trabalha com programação sabe que
existem dezenas de formas diferentes de
se resolver o mesmo problema
algumas delas na sequência de operações
algoritmos que a gente chama são tão
inusitadas que para quem não entende
aquela solução quando você olha
simplesmente parece mágica e não tardou
para que nesse celeiro fértil de início
da programação da da programação dos
computadores é começar sem aplicar o
termo rec nesse contexto quando alguém
encontrava uma solução extremamente
inusitado e eficiente para um algoritmo
para resolver um problema
aquilo começou a ser chamado de rec por
quê porque tinha primazia técnica porque
na hora que você olhava o código você
mergulhava dentro da cabeça da pessoa
que tinha encontrado aquela solução ou
seja uma forma de expressão e por que
sei lá era legal né
principalmente quando você conseguir
fazer o sistema fazer coisas que eles
supostamente não deveria fazer como
vocês podem ver aqui
essa história de não haver mídia de
armazenamento levou ao surgimento de uma
cultura de celebração a esse tipo de
habilidade nasceram os primeiros hackers
das pessoas que eram mais prolíficos na
criação desses apps dentro da computação
e como não havia a mídia de digamos
assim armazenamento não sei se os rolos
mas é difícil de ler o código lá começou
a se criar uma cultura de simplesmente
deixar os programas escritos em cadernos
não editados em cadernos que ficavam
dentro de gavetas mesmo porque você está
fisicamente neste espaço vão poder ter
acesso ao equipamento ea partir daí as
pessoas perceberam o quanto isso era bom
para a troca de conhecimento quanto será
produtivo como todo mundo podia se
beneficiar se você deixasse o código lá
ea pessoa pudesse aprimorar em cima
daquele código e aprender com aquele
código e assim por diante
esse equipamento e também o laboratório
de inteligência artificial do haiti onde
está a alma
estudava eram são considerados também o
berço daquilo que a gente hoje conhece
como cultura open source
à medida que começou a ocorrer inclusive
uma profissionalização da computação
no começo eram uma mistura de alguns
professores da faculdade com esses
outsider esforçando porta dentro
querendo ter acesso se sentindo donos
daquilo
mais do que a própria universidade a
profissionalização começou a levar
coisas tipo direito autoral devemos
proteger o código código deve ser
livremente acessível ou não e isso
obviamente provocou reações nessa
comunidade que via o processo como algo
muito mais importante que o resultado
final essa maneira de interagir esses
valores e assim por diante
e esse processo a cultura ofensores pra
mim é uma das coisas mais das coisas
mais seminais dentro da cultura open
source é isso aqui o spacewar o spacewar
é considerado um dos primeiros jogos de
videogame e vamos colocar dessa forma
ele rodava no pdp um que é um
equipamento você pode ver um pouquinho
menor aqui começou a se chamar essas
coisas de minicomputadores em contraste
aquele negócio enorme computadores é o
pp ainda não é considerado exatamente um
mini computador mas já está em vias de
um jogo que lembra o asteróides e para
mim poucas coisas representam melhor a
cultura hacker do que a cena gamer de
alguma forma porque dentre as muitas
coisas que poderiam ser feitas com
equipamento de um milhão de dólares
certamente jogar videogame não era uma
dança mais urgentes
mas mesmo assim resolveram fazer porque
ela passa a ser a partir deste momento
começa a ter fins em si próprio a
computação pela computação a computação
como meio de expressão a computação como
estilo de vida inclusive eram lá era
muito complicado jogar porque como falei
esses computadores eles não tinham um
teclado e tinha umas chaves então você
tinha que operar as chaves tal aqui
surgiu o controle de videogame foi
desenvolvido o controle do jogo só para
facilitar para jogar esse jogo e ele era
copiado aprimorado trocado entre outras
universidades
pelos estudantes em versões distintas né
pode se até dizer que ele foi
desenvolvido quase que de maneira
colaborativa
como é que é uma coisa tão legal como é
que uma cultura tão massa passou a ser
associada com crime com coisas do tipo
para a gente entender isso a gente
precisa entender uma tendência que a
gente já começa a ver aqui que essa
tendência de miniaturização que é o
surgimento da computação pessoal é não é
difícil supor que esse pessoal quer
atrair os computadores e queria ter
acesso a esses equipamentos não queriam
ter que ficar dividindo o computador
a questão de você ter os computadores
diminuindo até que eles virassem objetos
de uso pessoal era além de uma questão
mercadológica quase que uma necessidade
para esse tipo de gente viciada entrar
em contato com esses equipamentos o que
vocês estão vendo aqui é o computer
livre machines é considerado o primeiro
manifesto a respeito da computação
pessoal primeiro livro do assunto
praticamente um fanzine autopublicado e
ele foi lançado pouco tempo antes do
alterne o alterno isso que estão vendo
aí é considerado assim o primeiro
computador pessoal comercialmente viável
ele era inicialmente vendido como um kit
de montagem é para esse equipamento que
a microsoft lançou o primeiro produto
que era um interpretador basic é aqui
que costuma se dizer que nasceu a
cultura de pirataria o bill gates
escreve uma carta pedindo aos hobbies
pistas não é como era chamado pessoal
nessa época parar de duplicar o
interpretador base que ele tinha
desenvolvido para o hotel sem pagar a
licença e no vale do silício como em
muitos outros lugares os estados unidos
haviam o o o club med robusta sehac o
chamado rombo computer club onde havia
duas figuras bastante conhecidas que
viram esse equipamento e olharam lá na
frente ou seja muita gente gosta de kit
mostra que gosta de montar o próprio
computador mas muita gente vai querer
também comprar um computador pronto e
aqui também os hackers lançaram uma
longa tradição como vocês vão ver que em
algumas fotos de basicamente define em
termos estilísticos o que você não deve
fazer em termos de cor
de cabelo
só que embora muita gente acha que o
primeiro computador o primeiro produto
da apple foi o é bom esse equipamento
que estão vendo aqui uma espécie de kit
parecido qual terry depois o apple 2 que
foi o primeiro assim mais bem sucedido
comercialmente o primeiro equipamento é
tem um clube um documentário netflix
chamado a entrevista perdida onde steve
jobs fala que o primeiro produto da
apple na realidade uma blue box estão
vendo a boo-box às boxes são basicamente
dispositivos para cometer fraude
telefônica
eles viram uma matéria de capa na
revista escolher com hackers dessa
geração dos 60 ainda chamado de don
draper é o capitão implante que hackear
o sistema telefônico com um apito e aí
eles achavam que a história era uma
lenda urbana correram atrás encontrar
uma solução eles se não me engano a
história documento eles chegaram até ser
presos e foram soltos porque a polícia
não entendeu que o dispositivo fazia
olhar os dois de pombo cabeludo descalço
no orelhão com um negócio meio pendurado
assim falar um pouco essa vocês estão
fazendo mas a gente não sabe exatamente
que então vamos soltar vocês essa
cultura de contestação porque a fraude
telefônica porque nessa época os hackers
eles basicamente congregavam se em
diversos clubes acesso remoto aquilo que
a gente chama de bbbs acesso à internet
né
nos anos 80 mas aqui uma mostra um
cabelo degradante
a gente tem a popularização dessa figura
do hacker adolescente que invadir
sistemas essa é a primeira vez que uma
revista coloca o termo hacker na sua
capa de maneira pejorativa e isso pegou
igual rastilho de pólvora sair um filme
no ano seguinte em 1983 war games uma
história de um adolescente que vai
impressionar uma menina no quarto dele
disparava uma guerra nuclear a partir do
seu dormitório neuromancer é publicado
nessa época a mídia falou aqui uma peça
fundamental na literatura saber punk a
história de um hacker também serviu de
inspiração para uma tomada por metrix
ghost in the shell e os anos 90 eles
começam com essa pegada que parecia se
irremediável dessa imagem negativa do
hacker
os externa é outro autor do cyber punk
escreveu o hacker para que deram
contando a história dessa porque isso
gerou uma histeria coletiva na sociedade
imagina que se hoje tem gente que tem
fobia de computador imagina no final dos
anos 70 e começo dos anos 80
então isso gerou uma histeria coletiva
que levou à aprovação das primeiras leis
típica do tipificando o crime de
computadores mas muita gente achou que
essa pena seguir são era um pouco
excessiva que a polícia de repente
estava forçando a barra em algumas
coisas só para se ter uma idéia se você
fizesse uma invasão de computador que
causasse mais de 10 mil dólares em
prejuízo
você podia ser sentenciado a até 20 anos
de prisão sendo que a pena média nos
estados unidos para estupro é de cerca
de 8 a 9 anos
então para combater esse exagero os
hackers começaram a se organizar ff a
primeira ong fundada para tentar
defender os direitos em casos
importantes dentro do universo digital
foi fundado inclusive com dinheiro que o
próprio iraque deu foi fundada um dos
fundadores é o criador do lótus 123 que
alguns de vocês talvez saibam que é o
precursor da planilha eletrônica e nos
anos 90 é o ano que marca a
popularização da internet o software
open source torna homens trinco com
linux ea sociedade têm uma dificuldade
de entender quem são essas pessoas
a maior criação dos hackers da própria
internet
se existe uma coisa que expressa a
cultura e esse espírito é a própria
internet na sociedade passa a conhecer
que grande parte da internet funciona no
código que foi desenvolvido de maneira
colaborativa sem que ninguém seja
especificamente dono disso nessa
transição das bbbs que eram esses
sistemas que usava se para se conectar
de maneira remota né prazer pra internet
ocorre a primeira def con hoje a maior
conferência hacker do mundo que começou
em las vegas só como uma grande festa de
zueira de despedida das bbbs e percebeu
se que o tamanho da cena o tamanho da
quantidade de pessoas que gostariam de
estar em contato o filme que melhor
registro nessa época o filme hackers fim
da década de 90
o filme que lançou angelina jolie o
estrelato e
mostra essa começa a mostrar esses
dilemas éticos confusos porque uma coisa
quando você faz o era nos computadores
basicamente quem usa computador são
outras pessoas igual a você
outra coisa quando a sociedade começa a
ter infraestrutura crítica dependendo
desses sistemas
então inevitavelmente esse limite entre
o que é legalidade ou não ele ia chegar
o primeiro um dos mais famosos casos de
prisão do kevin mitnik até hoje
considerado hacker mais famoso do mundo
ele passa a cinco anos preso oito meses
em solitária porque segundo ele a
polícia conseguiu convencer o juiz de
que ele teria capacidade de iniciar uma
guerra nuclear a subir ano um telefone
público e aí a gente pode dizer que de
certa forma os rebeldes contra atacam no
começo dos anos
no começo dos anos 2000 é nos anos 2000
que o rec começa a se identificar como
uma força política com o surgimento do
anonymous
com o surgimento do partido pirata
professando alguns elementos dessa
cultura é também nos anos no começo do
século 21 que surge o bitcoin eo pitboy
coloca um elemento de confusão na
cultura hacker é muito grande porque até
então muita gente achava que o anonymus
ou talvez o partido pirata eles eram
meio libertários de esquerda não estava
muito claro que é
e aí o bitcoin uma moeda eletrônica
transacionada pela internet que ninguém
sabe quem criou e que funciona à revelia
do sistema financeiro internacional
parece um capitalismo anárquico nem gera
muita confusão para as pessoas tentarem
entender o que é isso e com obviamente
elementos dessa cultura tomando tantos
aspectos a gente começa a ver atores de
estado entrando nesse processo também a
operação aurora é considerado um dos
primeiros grandes casos de um ataque
sofisticado financiado por um estado no
caso a china contra empresas americanas
já em 2010 né
o stuxnet o primeiro caso de uma chamada
cyber arma um vírus de computador que
foi desenvolvido em parceria pelo
exército americano em israel para ser
utilizado para sabotar uma usina de
enriquecimento de urânio no irã
e começa a se também com as revelações
do snowden a compreender o tamanho do
protagonismo que serviços de
inteligência governos e tetra já estavam
desempenhando dentro dessas temáticas
incluindo a criação de frentes de
combate cibernética nem os americanos
eles criaram o 5º comando porque eles
consideram basicamente o cyber como um
quinto front de combate além de ar terra
água e inteligência que chama ea gente
entra nessa década o final dela num não
daria mais para a sociedade tentar se
dar ao luxo de não querer compreender
essas figuras tão controversas e o rec
na minha visão nesses anos recentes ele
alcança verdadeiramente assim o status
de ministro em coisas como a ti dogs uma
franquia de games que já está na sua
segunda edição é mas nada nada nada se
compara a série miss e roubos
a série estreou um fenômeno de crítica e
de público tem toda uma geração de
profissionais apaixonados pelo elliot é
um anti-herói que durante o dia convive
com as trivialidades da etiqueta do
trabalho da sociedade de consumo e que à
noite vive uma vida paralela tendo que
confrontar as revelações da verdade que
vem as mãos dele por conta de suas
próprias habilidades né
e aí eu acabo com uma necessidade ou
talvez até uma dificuldade que é como é
que a gente tenta concluir uma história
que ainda não acabou né eu acho que a
mensagem que eu teria para dizer seria
de que hackers são figuras contestadoras
que escolheram a tecnologia como suporte
para suas ambições pessoais
profissionais e artísticas
eles são uma força também né são também
uma força disruptiva na política tão
disruptiva como as idéias que eles
professam então tentar necessariamente
interpretar isso como bem ou mal é na
melhor das hipóteses uma iniciativa
muito diz trata de uma iniciativa muito
desastrada da imprensa
a resolver uma confusão que ela mesma
criou acho que hackers eles são muito
diversos para você tentar construir uma
narrativa única
eles são muito complexos para serem
encaixados em noções maniqueísta de tipo
bem ou mal por nós ou contra nós
esquerda ou direita mas acredito que
poucas culturas impactaram de forma tão
ampla e tão profunda a maneira como as
cidades como as sociedades elas
funcionam e se organizam isso é uma
coisa que eu tenho certeza é que a gente
não vai conseguir responder essas
perguntas nem professar de certa forma
essas discussões sem te a eles numa
posição de protagonismo
então voltando à pergunta inicial que é
quem o que é hacker
talvez essa pergunta ela tenha se
tornando obsoleta
veja o exemplo aqui das palestras que a
gente teve ao longo do dia nesse teste
dada a amplitude com a qual a tecnologia
impacta a sociedade hoje é dado o mundo
hiperconectado que a gente vive talvez a
pergunta mais apropriada não seja mais o
que é rec e sim o que não é
acredito que hoje em dia é muito pouco
[Aplausos]